it's son and his tastes broccolini get
your life together
they see if one goes with you goes with
that outfit you got on brought that
whole business look man I gotta go to do
some business today are we shooting me I
don't have any style man that's the
problem with you guys you look like an
extra narco like the gringo pilot dude
you look like John Gailey you look like
John Daly via Corona fire though you
didn't get a perm you didn't get
up-to-date son you just like it would
you watch the shampoo huh
having shoulders I did shampoo yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah you just dropped off the kids or
just stop drop off about seven kilos of
cocaine Pablo Escobar sir I will go with
the kilos on ya Pablo Escobar you look
fired fired me out dressing like music
you're making fun of me dude no not at
all all right mm-hmm
you guys are so apparently guys don't do
a lot of business I guess probably you
doing business on the golf course what
you doing Doug I got some business
meetings uh okay so guys nobody dress
like this don't talk to me I'm on
business call dude I busted out though
what you know about the slip and slide
oh I saw that date I saw your Instagram
do that kid halfway split slidin but my
girl set up with her Mexican friends and
Mexicans don't know how to slip and
slide really they didn't give him enough
room to run they didn't put any soap on
it
well they got limited legs brought Mex
it a lot of extra people of limited
length
lately right you right there 80% up our
[ __ ] up I backed it up put some soap I
said hit that [ __ ] now really yeah you
gotta for that soap on there yeah dude
you gotta put that soap man I throw
anything in there Lysol if we did enough
soap weed spray that but your lifestyle
and if you put some grease down some hot
grease right here oh it's not bad if you
close your eyes when you do it see this
key don't make them [ __ ] like they
used to when I was a kid we used to have
the metal plates on the side through the
forks there's really you know I he
finished through though we couldn't
finish through it is they oh hell no
what did you run through it at the end
hell yeah finish the Mexicans you know
how to set that thing up though well
yeah a lot of Mexican or Mexicans or 80%
torso to dog they are bro he has a point
you know that's Mexican Olympic swimmer
go doesn't exist yeah that's a trick
question
yep I like this I like that you gave it
some thought I tried
really Ector agua I bet you think
eggther agua in a fricking good idiot
and then I remembered what did you hear
that [ __ ] is fire son feels a little
distracting today let's go get it cut
today I cut it a little bit myself but
uh this is I haven't that sharp I wonder
what that [ __ ] look like blowing in the
wind brushes you got that forget planet
that [ __ ] is too far for planet dude or
plants on fire right now look like
Captain Planet Fitness dude
[Laughter]
pop out of the dressing room shitty
gymnasium look like you only working on
the glutes hey spot I'll hold your ass
[Laughter]
dude Anytime Fitness is gangster I come
in one time to am stole a motor out of a
frickin treadmill in pocket yeah yeah
dude
what do you expect when the membership
is $18 a month I went to one in New York
at 2:00 in the morning dude the Warlocks
though in the morning alone tuned
everybody on meth and all the treadmills
are taken Oh bro they yell when I was
there one time it was uh they had a guy
came through selling flowers to people
and [ __ ] it's chaos there's no front
desk
you just walk you steal protein powder
it's just like with those trust trees
you know yeah yeah it's I mean it's all
it's really yeah it was real
questionable in there my fitness dude oh
but if they're gonna they're gonna make
this whole lockdown Korona thing I don't
see them sticking around
I don't know man it's basically it's
every person for themselves
I feel like Chandu the Asian community
do you guys go to play in a fitness
24-hour fitness
everyone 24 and why is it honor up maybe
because there's in the title as easy yet
it's supposed to be open 24 hours that's
why but they're not 24 hours and now
that's what sucks then I'll open 20,000
not all yeah when I first got here I
used to go to 24-hour fitness and it was
I went to the one in Irvine and it was
like big trouble now we're drive oh I
heard some of them are in open 24 hours
because there was a lot of
extracurricular activity between the men
late at night oh really time with that
steam room hitter yeah for this episode
democratize ya know calm dungeon will
get us the monitor drink yeah well like
six minutes that it's been like yeah
just get the first five minutes yeah you
might be right it's kind like gonna go
to Cinnabon II get extra icing that's
what the steam rooms are like it's
always that ricin is it
no heavy yeah yeah misty monetize shout
out to Cinnabon they follow me on
Twitter for some reason let's say you
know you're fat I saw him dropping
comments like hate this so bad look good
luck with your stick boy bites I'm like
hey I don't need this sponsor you're the
reason it started yeah Brynn is like
Brennan look Brennan
it goes undercover he trusts attendees
at working work set aside he's like I'm
hero to fix the cinnamon maker I'm here
to check your levels on your cinnamon
yeah heard we ahead a uh but you guys
are low on pecan pecan you're unhappy
cutter let me check and make sure will
you do now you let me bring my partner
in there captain there you go
yeah do crazy weekend man dude I'm had
to do [ __ ] I'm headed to Phoenix
are you really earth day for why up the
capacity three hundred first show not on
[ __ ] sold out this to me flexing my
tits phoenix arizona' phoenix'
and earn and raise every day up there
that's your old hood isn't it it is my
Chappell car you think I'd go to Phoenix
not bring this great Chappell he's going
to hell yeah oh damn darker watch need
to get a dark you're gonna get a tan
dude somebody was saying with all like a
you know the protesting and all the with
police black for no mind said they're
gonna start painting white people black
and calling the cops on them we don't
need that I mean that's next level I
feel like you know like damn bro let me
know when that goes if you want me to
log down there to do it that's the way
to do it they might just leave me though
sorry a little bit of caramel Wow oh
yeah one do you just dressed up did he
get beat up they arrested him for it
that's not that same in blackface that's
charcoal face like that's but hold on
there's no people that have a does that
have a pigment issue where their skin is
burnt as like a charred look to it it's
called vitiligo though good alone they
get that felt like a model she is all I
have that you do yeah I go on my back oh
really
you're like spotted like a Jersey cow on
your back yeah you can really see it
when I get drunk cuz the rest of my body
will turn red and then just the vitiligo
part is pale you know like a lava lamp
almost like a no way she's she's the
model yeah she's so bad yeah cool yes
you got that look that's how I look if I
sneaking to get a little bit ice cream
right that's how I look after I [ __ ]
fit so Cinnabon machine guys like oh you
have caramel in the back here sure
thought I missed a little caramel all of
your ankles
yeah I don't know yeah you're broken
how's that too
all over his hands you can't tell cuz
he's sleep DUP he has an all over his
hand oh really yeah mm-hmm
vitiligo it sounds cool it does sound
cool she looks super hot but if you look
rough on some people
you'd think mmm I mean makes you
different I guess that spotting the
spotted the Spotted Cow you look on your
Jersey cow if you had some of it would
really stand out if you went white arm
or something for what no white arms
would be sick I used to go engine arm
sometimes I've had to take a test at
school I would Asian arm up a little for
I do in there did help did help uh I
would still cheat it off of people so I
did a matter of it asian arms white
brain other kids pave where'd you go to
college oh yeah yeah dude I was in there
bro I spend a good bit of time going
into college dude going on going to
college no class college called sports
or back though Doug are they really
football to all the football players on
campus as we speak wearing a college
football and I fell this season notice
how NFL two haven't said [ __ ] about less
people in stadiums or anything what's
that say god damn a listen a little
lunch bro pika [ __ ] damn just cuz you
walked across campus doesn't mean you
went to college
he was just performing for NACA yeah I
hit some man we did a little bit of work
out there bro somebody's got to do it
dude this coming from a guy who's not
familiar with college really play
football dude I did major in from what
class did you do what could be what did
I major in their business and sociology
double major sociology oh [ __ ] yeah it's
called degree where's yours at huh under
my arms dawg
alright
under your asian army now it doesn't
sweat actually dude I got an agreement
frame I got a friend degree celebrities
were like yeah I got my degree from
Harvard online remember Nicki Minaj like
I got a Harvard degree really all the
celebs are doing that [ __ ] yeah degrees
well you can take classes from Harvard
online hmm you just have like an Asian
kid take it for you
the guy from egos just got his high
school diploma really yeah
Wow congratulations I wore the what is
that guy's name snow cone or something
what's the difference he goes his name
his name's quavo Cueva well I barely
passed route and if you don't want to
show up this in he's so happy you got a
senior photo Griffin at least the song
to celebrate not just dude can you
yeah it's dope he got that baby they
don't give up man you know you high
school diploma
sky's the limit honestly it's crazy he
wasn't going to school you don't think
no like they go to a high school in
you're 29 man no you can't especially
when you're famous yeah or when you're
29 but it's illegal because what if you
start dating somebody at school and
they're gonna be young probably good
chance unless you and your girl both go
back oh his girl his girl smartest [ __ ]
went to USC with me oh sorry D obsolete
yes
so we was shot she is she was a
journalist major I think she's a rapper
- oh she's bad so you know I'm black you
can't take a frickin you can't bring a
girl back to high school with you also
that's crazy
you can't like I'm going back to high
school my girls coming back to high
school Billy Madison did it I've never
seen Billy Madison
sowwy you've never seen Billy Madison
but you brought that [ __ ] angus
movie oh my god she is delicious
she got her height high school degree -
no she graduated from USC Oh question
should I get a girl should I get tatted
I mean she has no tattoos that's just an
edit Oh fake Brendon good lord
that's faker I get my high school
diploma again for her I'd go back yeah
you know why I go back over Lin high
school and go back and do it again but
if you go back to high school dude I
don't think you'd do that good at it
though oh you don't think you would
either honestly you're doing it your
brains in other places man you couldn't
handle all that I'd like to assume I do
pretty good high school now also why
that principal mr. Buckner I dare to
grab my [ __ ] elbow again dude
hi dear you mr. Buckner what's up bro he
would grab all the kids like this think
about it you should been fired huh y'all
deserved it
what do you think due to your elbow
there's no sexual about Mazen start of
the sensual mmm no I thought it was mean
oh wow what a little squeeze what'd you
do to him just start living dude I was
living I was trying to better myself no
he grabbed all of us like that oh I'm
like to a mr. bike thanks that was real
cool
grab me now bro should we do some SAT
questions next week yeah yeah dude blur
man yeah you sure you want that deal
yeah I'd be fine brother the first time
it seemed like a little bit of a
struggle for you really what you get
into SATs huh tiramisu cheese you don't
naming cheese's isn't on there you said
red cheddar okay sweet red cheddar
that's a type of cheddar cheese
did you I didn't even take my SATs for
kcpt's nope I didn't take it I went to
Community College after high school and
then transfer it into USC without it
usually kids go to Community College
because they're a little bit of fuck-ups
in high school yeah it'll ground you
went to Community College yeah I'm
College you cheer at Community College I
did oh my pay for uniforms and [ __ ] no
do not like I got a Scott a full ride
scholarship for Cheers wait for cured at
Community College yeah here's the thing
about cleaning colleges like there's
some football programs cheerleading
programs especially wrestling programs
or there a lot of them are better than
division yeah yeah I went to Trinity
Valley Community College that's in like
Athens Texas in a small town and they're
really good about like helping out with
like athletes and [ __ ] there's a bunch
like you know John Jones was Community
College wrestling wrestler he was a
tomorrow Iseman not cheerleader this is
John chose to be the biggest cheerleader
ever though it's Junior College and
Community College same thing yeah right
yeah I think so I don't know Community
College is more like a group of people
in the area
yeah like hey what's a metro in Denver
you were real [ __ ] that man my dad's a
professor that's also we met my stepmom
she was a student dang really metro
though I mean but those community groups
those community colleges you can like
there's like adults they're adults they
community college class adults for what
just adults are like missed out on life
they go back to try and find their way
Community College usually is something
they do at the high school at night I
feel like that's what I feel like
Community College is so that's why I was
shocked there was a cheerleading team
there cuz I'm like ah
if these people were just coming over at
night to do learning why are they yeah I
think practice since you're leaving what
2:00 a.m. or something just seemed
insane to me so I'm sorry about that man
I didn't mean but you're awfully quiet
did you go to college I did I went to
university Minnesota
I didn't finish though I dropped out to
play poker because I'm an idiot but I
got a 31 on my a CT really yeah to
gamble yeah I made like I was living
with college roommates I made like
$40,000 in nine months online but like I
was just smoking a bunch of weed and not
going to class and I dropped out I don't
know if I'd brag I'm not on a CT no
that's wrong no one is good thirty one's
really good any 30 or higher is really
good no it's good
I got 32 32
I'm a CT CT I'm I'm impressed but I
consider that really good yeah yeah I
consider both of them good huh you can't
say 31 you can't say 31 is bad and 32 is
I think yeah yeah this is some big
scores 34 will get you into like any
place in the 36 as high as you can get
right yeah I don't know if they changed
cuz they added like a writing portion
and stuff now but how long is it - I
don't know 3 4 hours or something four
hours SAT - no SAT was big and ever SAT
was bigger than the a CT because if you
want to go to California school you need
the SATs yeah West Coast has SATs East
Coast as a CT we didn't have it SATs I
don't think really we had a CTS and we
had and the SATs out of 1600 we had leap
leap test if you want to go to the next
grade you have to take this hair I don't
have that but then they let mini all em
efforts in the end of the grades rough
gonna let in half y'all on the grades
can't even read freakin half you guys I
think at your arm painted ok struggling
in class
Nick dropped out to be a high school
[ __ ] play some poker bro you tell me
man and then one day you just logged in
I'm re dropped out of school and like
you signed into the poker sites and the
feds seized everything it's called Black
Friday and poker circles and like you
just couldn't play anymore so then then
I got a job at Sports Authority
super more authority is nice though yeah
also Louis dart dart dart I think dart
Sporting Goods and Denver they switched
them yes yeah it started an eagle
Colorado actually good how far were you
into school all the way I have like I
literally like us a little more than a
semester do you ever want to go back
like quavo ah maybe one day but it's
definitely not necessary to anything I'm
doing now how'd you get above producing
podcast I got I was sleeping in my car
and I got an internship at the Adam
Carolla Show I literally moved from
Minneapolis to LA because I thought
podcasts were growing and I wanted to
work for it and I listened to curl every
day listen to you guys I went to you the
first day I was living in my car I went
to a live show of fighter in the kid it
would it was that it was that it was
during the day it was like on a Tuesday
a social media week LA and 2015 yes it
was in Santa Monica yeah I was in the
crowd I wasn't really yeah oh my god
that was our first live show yeah and I
mean it was a nightmare because there
were like seven people in the crowd they
didn't know who we were I was like
cussing out there that I can't buddy no
and did burn didn't does Brendan seem
any different now than he did been met
uh no see same goofy lovable guy I just
thought we just had Adam Carolla on he's
great man I would get all the [ __ ] that
dude's done yeah what a beast oh yeah
man he said uh he said uh he's done all
kind of he's a gearhead Crank Yankers
yeah joe manchin that boxing all the
documentary he does a ton of
documentaries if you're a car guy like
is Paul Newman dogs are second to none
he owns Paul Newman's car
it's a 4.2 million dollar car really
seen that car before let me keep it at
his studio mmhmm yeah I love Corolla man
it's a four million dollar car 4.2
million racecar driver it's kind of like
he says himself though it's really just
rich white white guys have too much
money you spend like they anybody can go
on those races but I mean they're at
local eject horses and stuff was that
him driving it yeah he's a pioneer
though man
especially in our he's on Mount Rushmore
for podcasting oh yeah
damn and he's smart he's trying to have
like a market for Paul Newman's old race
cars like there is for Steve McQueen's
cars they sell for like six million
dollars so like he's gonna have them all
eventually and like he's due putting out
docs just like the lure of Paul Newman's
racing career that's an investment like
he'll be able to sell that thing in five
years right for 10 million Wow it's
pretty cool wild man you got a new car
that you car outside
that's what baby mamas car oh it is oh
yeah that's right that protects the
kiddos amen brother [ __ ] bulletproof
all right [ __ ] do you say ship or ship I
thought you said ship dude you don't
need to see just listen bro just listen
yep folks need to adapt to this changing
world you got demands man you got
businesses you need to get stuff out
there you ship station deal you don't
need to see anything all you need to
know is when you're selling online get a
lot of orders it can be tough to ship
stuff out that's why King and the sting
we use ship station it's the fastest
easiest most affordable way to manage
and ship your orders few clicks boom
click a dog ship station makes it so
dang easy ship station helps online
sellers of any size get orders out
quickly you don't need to see you see
this save money on shipping costs and
keep customers happy no matter what
you're selling Amazon Etsy your own
website ship station brings all your
orders into one simple interface all
right ship station works with all the
major carriers including USPS blind
people FedEx UPS Amazon we got it all
dog you don't need to see that's how
easy it is look at the OSHA pancha
pancha pip ship ship ship happens and
right now King this thing listeners can
try ship station fo free 60 days when
you use the offer code k ATS make sure
your business is ready to meet the
demands of delivery culture get started
at ship station calm today
cooking on the microphone at the top of
the homepage microphones right here dog
click alright
type in K 80s there you go that ship
station comm then code K 80s ship
station comm make ship happen
brah I came in I've been working out so
hard I can't see you're working out are
your eyes fell out of your body and I
don't want to I don't want to gross out
the the viewers so I put these glasses
on I appreciate that
I need something green so I can see oh
yeah the doctor won't you need more
green in your life oh I can't see
cabbage I came to see spinach right now
well we're gonna help you see it all
because of what I'm talking about as
athletic greens it's the ultimate sir
it's the ultimate daily all in one
health drink and even though you can't
see you're gonna love it
it's beautiful it's got prebiotics
probiotics digestive enzymes added
revisions superfoods and more it's that
one-stop shop to help your little blind
ass Oh sounds nice
yeah support your nutritional needs
across five critical areas of health
stuff seventy-five vitamins and minerals
it has so many vitamins or minerals man
I could explain them to you do but who
cares man you're blind yeah you're right
I can feel it I can feel it and that's
what matters that side of greens doesn't
compromise at all on ingredients or
sourcing dude you could never it'd be
very hard for you with your sight
disability to be able to go and farm a
bunch of cabbage farm a bunch of
greenery to it get a bunch of seaweed
out the ocean or do something like that
if you tell me this is in powder form
which I can feel it out and then just
put a little drop into my cup mix it up
take a little sippy-sip yeah Jesus
Christ I can see Oh see what I can see
praise God he's back whether you're
taking steps toward a healthier
lifestyle or you're changing your visual
ability completely athletic greens takes
the guesswork out of everyday good
health why not just try it just jump on
over to athletic greens calm /ke 80s and
claim the special offer today 20 free
travel packs value at $79 with your
first purchase that's athletic greens
calm /k ATS speaking of tests I think we
have one that you guys would both like
because of Theo's tweet about in and out
a stirred up a lot conference lead lap
people were fighting about supported
this we brought it I did support a
Steel's drew brees
[Music]
[Laughter]
Dunamis fan guys done so much for black
community from people agree to rip him
open like that just because of a of a
stance that he hadn't who'd even heard
the question from that [ __ ] Mook
standing but but also the guy give him
the questions like why are you bringing
up the the national anthem again that's
four years ago bro I think I was just
making him either
the guy was just baiting a man yeah this
dude's done so much for New Orleans brah
that [ __ ] made me man well you're right
he's raised thirty five million dollars
and also New Orleans Saints we're gonna
be the San Antonio Saints if it wasn't
for Drew Brees so everybody shut your
[ __ ] mouth
is he a quarterback yeah dude he went to
Community College cheering don't hate on
him like that okay his race is under
attack they're painting white people
black and calling the cops on them right
now I know you're not even like a you're
like a you don't know worried white guy
like a white guy from Poland of course
he knows the bull rider he rode on her
bull for PBR probe the probably one of
the most entertaining players though
also co-wrote a bull yeah yeah drew
brees wrote Jessica Cooper jus breeze is
probably Jacinta the best player in the
NFL for the past ten years I think pound
for pound he's the best he got MVP ever
you ever he's only five ten hamper panic
over Peyton Manning yes he well he
retired welcome that's whatever but uh
Drew Brees is as far as like good humans
he'd be number one I'd assume rank by
every player he's the best person in the
NFL a week ago so when people are coming
after him it do you make sense but I
also look how he switched it he was I
got my bad I've you know
I misspoke Oh I worried was not a place
where I said it's disrespectful I didn't
know my teammates educated me and then
Trump's like noe Nia stand up for him
and then now he's an ally for that he's
that one of the biggest voices against
for black lives matters you know I'm
saying so it's like he's an ally a huge
out he's always but he was always an
ally he also grew up in Texas locker
rooms and football teams
you know like long's he been player for
effort twenty years after by the charges
he's 41 now stud I mean if he's yeah if
he's you throw it's beautiful I don't
know he's a first-ballot hall-of-famer
I mean if he's racist he's the bet he's
the most then it's it just would be
unbelievable there's no one in sports to
just more for City than him maybe LeBron
for Cleveland but LeBrons out because of
the stance with China he doesn't get a
vote anymore yeah he just could have
Ward I mean he could have worded his
interview a little bit better but yeah I
also got realized from Drew Brees
standpoint that that's how he feels cuz
that's his perspective also from his
family serving in right and that's it
that's a fair perspective for him like
if he like different people are gonna
have different perspective that's what I
don't like is that when people you're
gonna shut somebody down because their
perspective is different that's crazy
that would like be like me saying oh
well if your perspective is different
because you're black or because you're
Asian or because you're you know cuz
your questionable yeah then it then that
doesn't matter at all you know D'Elia
says Mexican they're for you well what
does he know we don't know what yeah he
thinks things gonna be different they're
not D'Elia won't leave his house so he
doesn't get a vote yeah yeah the Lisa
tattoo sucked in he gets tattoos dude
police have weightlifting sucks Vinny
[ __ ] he starts shooting up membership
to Planet Fitness yes you know and then
he just said racism sucks bro just wait
give him two or three months
see what his tweets like like oh who's
that extremely tall Klansmen over there
huh who's the 7-foot tall Klansmen
Realty is real skinny Lloyd you see his
little ankles at the bottom now his legs
getting bigger
his quads can't do anything but
absolutely he's been drinking that
coffee through the front of his outfit
husband has coffee stains over the front
leg class who's the Klansmen easy all
right what do you got big all right
let's get into the episode man so I want
to do a test I think you guys would
appreciate its a blind burger taste test
oh I knew you'd like it
are you down to try some burgers oh yeah
all right I'm vegetarian and do not
cheat Brendan I'll try not to
bro yeah you look like some cops fat
horse some buddies but you look like
weekend at Jerry Sandusky's hey I can
only picture you look like it you look
like you trade pogs for dick pics Yeah
right
Yeah right then well agree the slammer
you just get a sneak peek at your dick
oh let me hold your dick for a second
dude it's not gay if you hold somebody's
dick for a little mom a few trade for
pogs bro so in front of you we've got
four burgers staples Oh
smell Umbra yeah yeah and they're on
individual plates so you're not peak
Brendan I'm not dude you will you're the
kind of guy who would freaking cheat on
something like this no you're gonna
cheat dude well yeah they're there in a
line in front of Brendan and then the
Oman so what's the contest yeah yeah
Chappelle passing do you ladies feel
like some nice tip bro I their burgers
you know what they feel like yeah you've
got four burgers staples I would say
just take a bite or two of each one and
then kind of rank them for us there for
different burgers yeah for burger
staples in a burger we had extra for you
Chappelle oh so what do i do just bite
it knew we loves chin just bite into it
and then I would we also have a paper
towels on the can't see you [ __ ] yeah
but I can imagine do not tell me what
they are
yeah I think I think guess at the end
what you think they are along with your
ranking yeah yeah there you go wow you
don't have a nice vanilla shake to watch
your step and these are for mainstream
yeah oh wait is everyone playing to
adjust this to me - Brendan has all the
burgers oh my god cuz I thought the
first thing was this company bottom lip
from meet me at 240 dogs I don't think
he's gonna be able make it anymore
burgers true huh best McDonald's
oh geez run if you don't shut up you
have sauce on your arms I can't see your
safe no tooth but ole's is driving no no
see that's not fair
first just rank them and then we'll tell
you what you picked hey don't eat them
all Brian for ya just dot want you to
start the test repeal okay this isn't
about you sure bill cuz I'm people out
there that are really starving and
you're giving them they think oh this
guy's a clown y'all better stop
bullshitting I'll tell what I could
really use a diet coke fat boy with a
diet dead last and then what are we
judging I thought it was which one is
McDonald's one two three four we should
have done this with whiskey but somebody
here's a [ __ ] quitter
whiskey's for gay men brought grab a
[ __ ] gram son all right
and see you to grab an eight ball how
about you do both brah
no yeah can you fly off the [ __ ]
hinges and murder everybody in here yeah
whenever you want CDO great wave of some
of your feel we're awesome we give feel
whiskey he's trying to suck us off
saying it's not gay
we bought you four burgers he still just
another throat Christmas we're going for
you and you can't pipe down I know I
need him not sniff them right do what
brendan has his order see oh yeah if you
want to put them in the order can I take
my glasses off yes no shake check you
both put number one and you both put in
and out four oh my god Wow
so proof and then number two was five
guys and three was McDonald's Wow your
number two has lettuce on it right yeah
yeah that's that's five guys and then
McDonald's so we went Shake Shack Shake
Shack Five Guys McDonald's in and out
and you wanna read that's that's that's
why that's crazy that's crazy
samesies burger boys huh paddy boys
that's crows you are so I know some
people are blind this is wave liner than
them bro no offence of anybody's blind
but I can't see [ __ ] dude you could be I
don't know what's going on I could be in
the damn birth canal bro you don't know
where you are
Wow Wow that took a lot of effort Nick
thank you yeah this is cool man I didn't
think about Shake Shack I didn't either
Thank You Jen Wow um I'm gonna go purge
for a little bit do you vomit do you do
you don't do that kind of stuff now I
would never have you ever done that
I sure have how do you really yeah for
what we're we would get to get trained
for eating disorders nah yeah did you
really a little bit Wow
you don't strike me like that like
somebody one of those commercials or
something I don't consumers got them
young girls yeah with the alien heads
and
anybody's yeah some people look like
this with the disorders I'm not to come
up swung cocaine at TSA and throwing it
up when you get okay
hey you rate a [ __ ] nice meal
throwing it up there I don't think I had
man I almost choked to death a couple
times on uh if I mixed Gatorade and tuna
fish at the same time better do it I'll
choke do I'm was not stopping a shots
now that makes sense
I must when I was young almost died at a
Taco Bell you know we almost died what
being a [ __ ] no I was young and I was
eating the nacho nacho you know the
cheese just a regular tortilla chips and
the cheese and I was I would get that
and churros that was my thing my dad
would take us there and I was like seven
just [ __ ] it's not your thing why it
was my thing isn't I'm flying through it
everybody can have that everybody yeah
but I would always get that you know and
they're like oh it's the bee shops yeah
my face turn blue my dad give me the
Heimlich oh man
my dad so it's about time shut the [ __ ]
up
what was it natural there's a tortilla
chips he said yeah rescue my son he
choking on food my debts are going out
there's guys you know and then you ended
up the community you know choked done
anything no I will almost drown one time
and a lifeguard at the beach had to save
me no way yeah that's embarrassing it
was was it a man or woman at sea it was
like an 18 year old girl give me
mouth-to-mouth she did not but she would
not and because it was my first time
swimming in the ocean and I got caught
in a Riptide or whatever yeah I didn't
know like I just thought I was just
floating skin and literally she comes
over she's like you can count real topic
I got to save you and I was like okay
cool
and so as she's pulling me back we're
getting closer I said hey look
let me finish the rest away you know
there's a lot of people looking you know
I let me finish this out I can get the
rest of the way and she was like no I
got to take you all the way yeah she
took me all the way everybody was just
and did it feel what I mean what was it
like did it feel
I mean what was it like I was looking
for her right
it was tight you know just like a few
weeks ago I was like 26 yeah no she's
hard man no it is real hard hard to
handle I mean it sinks pirate ships
ocean does all kind of stuff though she
knows all kind of shark Titanic magic in
it Titanic everything treasure yeah huge
whales all kind of stuff yeah
what do Asian people think of the ocean
you guys had fear it as well yes but
also I personally have a family that
does very well in the water mighty dad
and his grandpa were fishermen my dad
also swam in the ocean while he lived in
a refugee camp so Wow
yeah your Papa knows his way around some
water yep he was born in the water as he
said I was born in the water
you were kool-aid see it I was born with
the hi-c I uh
great huh those burgers hot Shake Shack
yeah didn't you know God that in and out
was a piece of [ __ ] I knew right away
there's a piece of [ __ ] funny bro it's
not been saying that y'all were too
important to me know I was supportive
you didn't you weren't supportive yeah I
will delete attacked me for that I
didn't I got someone [ __ ] daliyah's
manic and I really looks like you know
where she didn't know where you IDI cuz
I don't wanna be associated with
you're sticking up for your boys I'm
surprised your arms on her from carrying
Chris's dick around man that burger
contest that you know I feel heavy man
I feel heavy too cuz I hate that well I
just hate guessing what I'm about to
have you know what it wasn't fresh yeah
you're right it wasn't fresh nobody said
hello no they sure didn't but you know
what does hello fresh oh my god I set
you up for that America's number one
numero uno meal kit oh my god let every
week bro every week it lets you skip
those trips to the grocery it lets you
it takes the guesswork out of out of
dining it makes home cooking fun easy
and affordable it's delicious it's for
everybody including low-calorie
vegetarian family friendly every seeing
everybody man yep if you air buddy if
you're struggling if you're not
struggling if you're doing well suicidal
whatever hellofresh is for everyone
takes just about thirty minutes or even
20 minutes and bam you're ready to go
you a full meal it can save it to 28% by
using hellofresh versus your grocery
store don't forget your groceries yeah
because you're not gonna use those items
you might go get a uh thing of bison or
something you might go get a thing of
tomatoes man you gotta wear masks
yeah you get a thing a bacon powder you
get home you can't make Nothing with
that you know nothing hello fresh send
you things in a box that says hey this
is exactly how to make something you
know keeps your fridge stocked by adding
proteins and sides like garlic bread to
your weenie order you can do that easily
change your delivery days if you don't
like the bowl you talk about flexible oh
if you're gonna buy yes it's committed
hellofresh is committed to making fresh
delicious food it gives back man hello
fresh donates over 2.5 million meals of
charity just last year alone alright so
they're gonna keep on keeping on and you
guys get man you get something delicious
seal daddy go to hellofresh comm slash
60 k 80s news coat 60 cats to get $60
off your first three weeks including
free shipping on your first box quit
frisking burgers to see if something's
good just go to hello fresh com / 6 0 K
80
yes that's right hello fresh comm / 60
cats and used code 60 cats 6 0 K 80s to
get $60 off your first three weeks
including free shipping on your first
box additional restrictions apply please
visit hello fresh comm for more details
it's $60 off your first three weeks if
you haven't tried this man try it out
it's a lot of fun for the whole family
or even if you're lonely let's get into
a question here's some guy who looks
like he works in the police department
actually with the windows he does it
looks like using the back of the car and
what's up video James from Wareham mass
I got a little name game employer
professional Restless and I'll start you
off with that Texas rattlesnake hitter
Stone Cold Steve Austin my fav gang gang
buzz-buzz is definitely in the back of a
cop right there yes even like hanger
staying at a breaking key her snip
handcuffs they'd hurt one time a buddy
of mine got pulled over he had a pound
of weed on him right so we put it in
front of his pants the cops take him out
of his car put him into the cop car so
they can search his car yeah
search his car don't find anything
because he has it on him down in the cop
car and then they weren't him back and
let him go I'm Billy conforto and he
died actually two ate a bunch of pills
and oh yeah rest in peace forever bro
all right let's retain some wrestlers
you [ __ ] okay
I will start off with
[Music]
I mean I could easily start with the Rat
King myself but I'm gonna go with
fake-ass wrestlers mystic Rick I feel
like you've already taught us he doesn't
count okay I'll give you another chance
though I didn't think so either
uh uh I'm gonna go with um the big
bossman brother go with that Macho Man
Randy Savage okay I like that
i'ma go with that easy-peasy yep on me
say mr. Hulk Hogan with that bad Thai
hair dude I'm gonna go with that Jake
the snake II oh I think you need to get
that select trim like your boy right
here from Brutus le bottom a big oh my
go with what Theo does with his nuts the
Bulldog who's the Bulldogs the [ __ ]
Bulldog bring that up the British
bulldog
oh the British Bulldog is way different
than the both aw he's known as the
Bulldog the Bulldog if you're in Britain
I think he's just goes by the Bulldog
and my mom's from England and I'm half
English Counting uh-huh what else you
got another thing Britain is half I'm
gonna go with uh oh boy
Dusty Rhodes yeah
Ultimate Warrior ok I'm gonna go with
that damn Dusty Rhodes got to die
yeah he's dead he did just that I could
tell by that picture
hmm I'm gonna go with your boy Hacksaw
Jim yogi yeah well they call me this in
the sheets how about the animal the
animal come on Hawk and animal roadways
right uh I'm gonna go with uh I'm gonna
support BLM right here and go with Coco
beware
like I'm gonna hit you with a little
Undertaker okay Coco though bro he was
hot a spirit yeah beautiful parrot
alright I'm gonna go with flying right
gig will yeah I like that but how about
I hit you right in the heart with Bret
the Hitman yeah you pull him out front
of the bus you threw him under last week
huh who did you say huh flying Brian
Williams it's flying Brian Pillman Brian
Williams in the WWF see SEOs problem is
he goes to specific if you go bag we can
just count it but if you just said
flying Brian you would add it is it
Brian Williams this job but is in the
WWE slide I don't feel stupid you know
row yeah you are in let anything slide
bro you didn't know okay that's why I
never heard of Brian Wilson WWF but he
was a crazy boy yeah hadn't been here it
was just you but I want to keep going so
you guys ain't [ __ ] bro - brothers you
got the rock baby
I didn't want to public abca1 huh - bash
brothers also is not one you've done a
lot of game that's from that's from
Mighty Ducks they're the bushwhackers no
typing bash brothers look we also gave
this due to the Bulldog
yeah the bass brother says bushwhackers
don't bring up blast brothers yeah
the Baskervilles you'll get a video game
no the right there dude
there they are oh maybe double use the
bash brothers
oh no never these guys though are the
guys these are the bushwhackers oh yeah
yeah yep I'm with you bastards ain't ya
I was gonna hit you with that Yokozuna
ah
was he hit with that sable what's up bro
no no [ __ ] about save ever heard of
these fake-ass I was with Eve gracie bro
Ronda Rousey alright
China Blazer China China's one to bless
the piece anodized China dies it was the
hottest thing this side of misrata last
nerd that's probably girl whoo seller -
you know they're married yeah they're
married now really her her in him yep
they've been together for a hot second
what's her name sable sable is the rock
I don't know no yes she's a wrestler WB
champion three wdv I should say hmm well
it's fun one again well okay that
burgers hit me slow me down my brain
[ __ ] your pet
no I don't think anything is wrong with
my body I just [ __ ] my brain got slowed
out I said flying Brian Williams dude
what a great name who isn't us who's in
an announcer who also wrestled in
college didn't wrestle in college
damn II went to Mater Dei matter no you
didn't wrestle yeah but hold on go back
he said he was a boy at Perkins pancake
wrestle after work hey you know you
wrestled some lies in that helicopter
when he said he's in the war remember
that that's why you got fired
what about this so he suffered an
accident that left him with a crooked
nose that could have been wrestling my
first job was also busboy at Perkins
pancake house and we wrestled at night
but okay geisha not as beautiful man I
think you guys are doing it dude a
couple of men meeting up after work to
make sure everybody's doing okay aprons
off and wrestling over pie it's not good
in Wisconsin it only gave your gay after
you wrestle that's just that was only
half true we didn't wrestle but I was
busboy Perkins shot out man shout out to
all the Busboys out there yes you're
doing the Lord's work
yeah you can't make a whale and getting
no [ __ ] nobody gives you any credit
you can't make waiter dog it's the worst
bro like what's this idiot doing that I
can't do the issue is is that you are 16
years old that's the only issue and your
attitude you got a tattoo on your neck
any of us who spend your money on drugs
so there's also that shout out Rochester
do both of those things remind me of
Rochester hey buddy I'm on blacked out
in a drove home after we partied in the
parking lot of a Days Inn oh yeah we
can't have you as waiter then I'm here
Webster that's why you never made it
praise God here's somebody right here
with a little fella in the background
what that could be what time is that
Bryan Callen in the background
[Laughter]
what's up Brandon what's up do we got a
king under sting in for you getting your
ass waxed kids you gotta do the ring
though you got to do the a-hole if
you're gonna do it yeah you know it's
the number one thing for guys when they
get whacks what they call it balls balls
and butt really yep Wow I wouldn't mind
a little bit of it but I had my girl wax
inside of my side cuz I wonder wax ass
[ __ ]
mom I can me see how bad it hurts she
just wax inside my thigh bro it was the
worst pain I've ever been in I don't get
how girls do it what a little [ __ ] dog
dog I'll even gained five more meet me
at 2:45 oh I can handle the cuts on
that's all I'm saying you need to wax
that duck tail hanging off your back bro
no [ __ ] none of you guys have any style
in here okay chin has some style that
looks great but the rest you [ __ ] boys
don't have [ __ ] okay
you don't have to wet oh I'm talking
about do I still wet you still wax yeah
happy y'all ain't [ __ ] are you still on
that shitty hair broth see both you and
him have the same [ __ ] haircut you
and Brendan and little dark Brendan oh
[Laughter]
I'm sorry the store is all out of the
John Daly wig my bad bro this ain't a
wig you freak mm-hmm this is real hair
prove it so here comes a guy with a
decent oh wait wait I say look man yeah
I've got my butt my butt wax man you got
to do it sometimes bro especially if you
used to use steroids and stuff in high
school masse like Jumanji [ __ ] we
very thick I want to get it right now
really yeah go to the place and get it
done Persian lady will do it yeah oh
that's a rough they do what they beat
they'll [ __ ] call you their husbands
name while they do it they're angry
you've done it before yeah she got all
fours
oh you know yeah I look right in the
eyes well she does I say take it yeah
take it daddy
take it female daddy I said I say cuz
I'm a [ __ ] man one day take it mom
like it's your belt look scared over
there don't really who done that huh
yeah if you quit listening to matchbox
20 and get in the game all y'all man
y'all right from the lighthouse
soundtrack bro bro if you turn down the
face on that ktg a little and pretty can
have a life experience dog baby all
right
Brooks and Dunn live to get on all fours
and call someone mama where they rip the
hair out your [ __ ] bro
yeah dude if you back off the 24-hour
live feed from the four
[Laughter]
looking for deals on the hot topic
online you might live a little ship
double take it from Brendan who's
dressed like a bouncer at Christa Leah's
closet okay my gym Chris only man here's
somebody right here obviously doesn't
know what's going on here's a robe on
which is sick
this is a fashion related but let's
ignore the poor quality on its video oh
this is from the eighties hey what's up
Brendan was up vo Brandon from Maryland
gang a couple weeks ago on the episode I
heard you guys was rockin hating on
Chappelle a little bit about his uh that
Malibu piece of apparel he had on there
okay so here's my question to Bay Club
for you that Hawaiian shirt hitter wear
that flannel
what's the superior piece of clothing
gang gang bro on the situation daddy did
you look like real [ __ ] wearing that
[ __ ] tropical hit or you know you
don't wear it right I don't know I think
it looks good dope on you man that's a
dark rum commercial member dark Malibu
rum yeah yeah the Malibu rum fish is
hilarious shit's fire as their fire dude
I was so non-alcoholic mellow room cuz I
don't drink you know Ian half of Malibu
was in a fire anyway so that [ __ ]
actually really worked yeah um
there you go right there she's no Lacey
dark rum how about you say it make you
do a backflip two sips an extra pair
lacy dark rum - sips you'll be doing
cartwheels yeah it'll make you uh do a
triple axel run out of your community
college does it make you flip right into
a four-year college
I didn't go to war you I'm saying
yeah those ripped eyes won't stand a
chance
knuckle deep is it you should bring it
to Phoenix let's go to the roof you know
many people reached out to me to ask
where my girlfriend got that [ __ ] wow
she did what she say Staples Center do
they have closed their Lakers [ __ ]
nighttime Hill oh yeah bro oh yeah
that's that Jamie boy flea market was
your girl pisser and no girl watches
this show yeah I hope she does not we so
what'd you guys pick I like a nice
flannel you do yeah a nice blue nice
flat looks pretty dug with right genes
right cakes he looks pretty fly can
never go wrong with flannel yeah that's
a lady me Andy look at the way fields
dress for God's sakes and look at me
what do you think that oh I love
flannels especially flannels on a guy
using that like lumberjack lab I mean
you could get like that yak they call it
that L jet yeah oh dude yeah you know
Nixon it's gonna pick flannels I can't
see Nick and a Hawaiian shirt yeah you
don't drop out of college become a
professional gambler and wear Hawaiian
shirts going online yeah you can't make
any money real money in person five
tables at a time baby really mm-hmm
Wow it was honest and that's like when I
started really listening to a podcast
and [ __ ] so all things happen for a
reason you're the same thing just daddy
funded him you know Sam and what about
you chin how did you end up in the
podcast world um
it's a boring story though not really
it's kind of a dope story well I was
doing I was a producer and a voice-over
director for a Spanish dubbed Korean
television show it was a kpop show so I
actually directed people
voice over director to people in Spanish
oh wow yeah a little bit nice directing
people directing hold network's writing
people know they're actually they're
actually Spanish speakers but they're
dubbing / Korean television show kpop
joke did they have to speak English also
and you told that you you translated the
korean to english and just told them in
English no so we had a translator
do the entire sheet and then I would
just direct them how to say it to voice
act it was just voice acting I see but
then I did that and I rented my own
studio so I built the whole studio there
- mm-hmm
and I rented that on the weekends my own
with my own money and produced podcast
just to learn it and then Brennan and
finally Kate
Brennan was on Joe Rogan's podcast
they're looking for a producer and I
just randomly thought I'm gonna see him
at a show give him a thumb drive with
all my information on it all the shows I
did all his stuff he took it reached
that later boom would you do with the
thumb drive I did a set at the Laugh
Factory so what five years ago chin for
four oh four I was doing set The Laugh
Factory I got stage and chin was like
I'm your next producer or else yeah
samurai sword we're gonna do he was a
badass thanks dude
and this is actually haunted me for
years he came in to Corolla because he's
friends with Chris locks Amana who's
Adam Carolla's producer and I worked
there at the time and he came in just
like asking questions how they ran stuff
and he left and I wanted to apply I was
not qualified the time to like run a
podcast but I literally I go to Chris I
go I hope he doesn't get it like that
was just bad juju you got a room for
people I feel bad wishing the darkness
on people move in there brother I've got
I got it off my chest
all right you're like everything's my
job where do I start
should we close it out with the King
understand yeah man that burger hit me
in the neck thing I didn't know I
thought we were picking which one is
which company and then so that's what I
tasted them all thing in that I just
wanted to prove if you did or didn't
like in and out there'd been hilarious I
picked in and out number one but we both
bring in dead last is that crazy
yeah Wow here we go I got a king at her
stinger for you boys
the Rat King watching over you on that
throne while you're dropping down a
hitter amen brother Gang Gang buzz-buzz
the Rat King
watching people think [ __ ] praise God
Bravo
why not a little art in there goes a
long ways yep
I think if you can look at some art or
something inspiring while something's
coming out of your butt then you deserve
to be able to do it well sometimes you
gotta push through sometimes it's tough
to get it out and if you look up there
and you feel probably did this you know
yeah yeah I think if you got it yeah if
you look at a nice art doesn't cocaine
make you constipated I don't think so I
finally they me go to the bathroom no is
it the opposite that's why people go do
it in the bathroom cuz they're in there
doing and I'm doing dude he's doing
super constipated
I don't think so I think if you do pills
for like oh that's right pills a long
time then you can't go to the toilet but
people I think people go to the toilet
too much anyway I probably poop maybe
two times a week seventy-three percent
said King eat good choices
27 percent had issues with it what else
do you want over your bathroom toilet
what is it some picture of like a boat
yeah you know art is the [ __ ] on a
sailboat it's extremely hard people who
have posters that says live laugh love
on them yeah alright if you're single
doing walking in girls room it says live
laugh love you know what's going down
[Laughter]
well yeah I think we'll come out with a
special artwork for toilet and bathrooms
a shower curtain
I think we'd come out some artwork for a
Captain Planet Fitness yeah sure getting
jacked in there yeah we're gonna we got
new stuff up to or we have to store
shop KHS up sh Opie yeah
due to some get you something my cash
shop going there get you something get
you something for you get you something
for the lady to a couple item you know
shirts my favorite we got short sleeve
long sleeve tanks no so yeah invisible
shirt he'll for nine dollars will send
you nothing at all nine dollars get a
box who is this gentleman I don't know
no he definitely what kind of vibe do
you think he gives off oh yeah oh my
erotic yeah a little professional
because he is that sunburnt neck
wrestlers body to match the color of his
neck well he has that farmer's tan it
looks like if you get on in on his arm
he does I think he's also has a little
dash of Asian as a looks very Filipino
Asian isms Asian ISM you might have
Asian ISM what's the other models look
like you see our only model he's the guy
man let's get some thick [ __ ] up in
there whoa there's some real big girls
mom men's shirts yeah why don't we have
how people do that just big broad just
[ __ ] big rods I think you're onto
something yeah maybe that guy in the guy
right here lost you talking about lost
yeah look man they're gonna ask him what
he got is SAT not good this guy there's
a mechanic shirt if you do mechanic's
bra yeah bro if you work at Ford Porsche
do you love Nordstrom Rack Nordstrom's
rack changing times
a little oil I the shirt bro so they got
a couple select items on there man if
you want a choice you want to look at
something or be in a shirt you got that
coffee mug to maybe you just don't want
to wear anything but [ __ ] rep king of
sting
so you got that mug gig get you a sip in
the morning something to quench your
thirst bro the little Java get your dick
out and drink some java bro
yeah bro hold your dick bro hold your
cousin's dick and have a sip of coffee
yeah dark roast and grab a handful full
of nuts
which it's a rhyme so no better way to
start the morning
Brock cut you nuts open dog you know and
give one um to your cousin cousin cousin
both share the mug maybe just get one
mug for the fish yeah get one mug for
the family brother do that 1800 style
y'all sharing a little bit of soup or
something
mm-hmm do a can of soup so but a lot of
items on there that's cat shop calm okay
80s shop calm and some people think it's
your shop cat a lot of people spell my
name with a k' thinking that you guys
named the show after me oh really not
know do people ah do you mind if people
spell cat ket no I mean I don't really
care either way cuz everyone calls me
cat he knows me through work but then
like nobody else outside of work calls
me cat ever right it started yeah you
did it's the flight when you call me
that because that's the nickname that
you gave me I don't really mind the name
cat but everybody calls me team what
about kitty if people say it's her it's
for her but I can tell she really you
couldn't tell she didn't like it yeah I
can't wear that shirt and ask if she
wants to be called kitty I've lost that
hey you want to have a seat when you
come here with a six pack full of Zima
an ass little cat you can call her kitty
this is off that right you [ __ ] brain
orphan this is a busy two forties all
right bro bro I'll beat you at the damn
yard shovel dogs you guys are out of
your minds bro you don't know this she
doesn't like the name cat for four years
and you're gonna show like so my father
she barely likes it she said she's your
family calls you team yeah yeah nobody
calls me cat outside of work yeah all
the fans call yeah yeah yeah which is
kind of nice can the Georgia the people
call you cat that mm-hmm
have you gone on any uh dates or met up
with anybody that's hit you up through
the show
uh no I have not wait no cake you have
have you been no I'm date I'm trying to
think yes
how's it been going um it's been going I
don't really I'm just learning that I am
one of two people while dating I'm
either super like super forward and very
aggressive or I'm a little [ __ ] like I
will not say anything yes it's one or
the other we'll try it probably based
off the dude the vibe with the guy right
yeah I don't know like some guys I'm
really aggressive with I'm very forward
and then other guy is like I can't I
won't even look at you you don't like
them or they're just are they super
alphas no they just make me nervous I
don't know what it is it's one or the
other
and what kind of ethnicity have these
men been white mostly white boys are in
my DM so that's all I've really got
right now
there was one Asian dude that I really
liked but he was the one I was
aggressive with I don't think he was
ready for that yeah I don't know what it
is like I'm putting it down and Asian
men just aren't picking it up are they
prepared cuz a lot of Asian men will
take their own lives
do they it seem like you can be
aggressive with them if they're willing
to take their own life they could handle
anything I just don't think they the
Asian guys I was hitting up were ready
for like a woman to come after them I
think they're used to doing the chasing
they're not used to someone just coming
up to them you like hi I want you like
let's go out with the white boys are
down huh yes my boys are super forward
and then I get shy yep you get shy when
they're really hands on yeah sometimes
sometimes well that's how it goes man no
dark meat wears a lot no like oh yeah
well point in my eyes haven't met the
right one but you like all all drivers
yeah is there anyone you like just not
my thing
what about a big Mexican dude I love
Mexicans yeah oh yeah love Mexicans a
lot of people in my dreams are Mexican
if I have dreams
that night I don't know I don't know all
that
should I talk to somebody about them I'm
talking to five my friends so many talk
huh talk to professional I'm not talking
to a freaking professor
really yeah quit talking your therapist
huh you quit doctor we'll run this idea
by her there has to be some reason for
it like there's people or dreams that
are Mexican man there's a lot of Mexican
people out there so you love doctors
what else I love Mexicans but Mexicans
never loved me growing up yep yeah same
that's right Caballero
that's me yeah a couple wet huh no
Caballero come by air overcome by arrows
c'mon cabrones routers maybe you were
Mexican in your past life
hey give me no nickname everybody you
got I can't see no I can't see them
haters boy you know what I'm saying I
can't see [ __ ] I'm supposed to go get a
haircut today really what are you gonna
do get it cut do you guys some you roll
my eyes through these you're just gonna
get a little trim down the back mm I
don't know
I'm gonna get different I'm gonna get
all parts of it cut I think you hit the
links after you just wearing that shirt
for the [ __ ] of it I told you if you go
to business thing oh okay okay
mm-hm not everybody does business with
their son on trails all the time
some of us have real business to do
I think this is it I think is it to find
yourself pounding pounding Brennan and
Theo fighter and wait I gotta go in and
go hard in the paint I do not think I am
in flow black rifle coffee I'm ready to
go I need a sponsor I am a monster about
to open up with this at my concerts flow
is contagious browser outrageous thicker
than girls leather Instagram famous damn
movie like a fresh off keto see a red
like Andrew Santino right every Sunday
it is like the great Bambino gonna take
the case oh and the case cerritos but
everything's gonna be fine
hate on me I do not mind got a pack of
matches in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my DMS a couple of you
Trevor couldn't beat em quit playin like
Nintendo DS you don't want the smoke
like Joey Diaz meaning y'all edible just
got my eyebrows read they did nothing
incredible Britt and Sun him me up he
said it's too loud in the club can you
pick me up
sting
and the sting bee sting Rat King
and a sting King a nasty beez in the
trap gotta cheese on a string
and the sting king and the stinking and
the sting bee sting crack king king in a
sting
and the sting of bees and traffic got
that cheese on a string
[Music]